you may remember when illegal aliens
took over the El Paso Airport that
seemed like a bad sign but it could get
worse it always can now the homeless the
so-called homeless have moved into
Chicago International Airport O'Hare
vagrants living in the terminals
sleeping by the baggage claims in one of
the biggest and most famous airports in
the world there's one custodian at
O'Hare put it it's out of control none
of us feel safe and you can say that for
the city itself Raymond Lopez is an
alderman in Chicago he has been a very
rare voice in that City calling for
sanity he's joining us tonight from
O'Hare Airport Alder Lopez thank you so
much for coming on what do you see there
Tucker now good evening Tucker as we
walk through the airport the fourth
largest airport in the United States
we've seen this beautiful gateway to
Chicago been overrun by the homeless
where every night two to three hundred
homeless individuals come off public
transportation and set up encampments
here in baggage claiming throughout all
five terminals all the while the mayor's
voice is blasting from overhead
welcoming any one of the 65 000 daily
visitors here in this indoor Outhouse
that we call O'Hare Airport
how could the mayor of Chicago allow one
of its most famous landmarks in a
Transportation Hub for the whole country
to be desecrated
by people urinating in it I don't
understand
you know they're not just urinating in
the hallways they're taking baths in the
toilets they're they're making a mockery
of what Chicago is here and we
understand that homelessness is a
problem we must address but making
O'Hare Airport a homeless shelter for
hundreds of people on a daily basis when
we're trying to welcome people here when
we're trying to encourage tourism bring
back the business clientele bring back
families to our city and to only have
them greeted by hundreds of homeless who
have mental health issues may be armed
maybe not even be clothed that's not
something that institutes a lot of
confidence in our mayor in our city and
clearly she doesn't care because she's
17 miles away from it
surrounded by City Finance bodyguards
unlike you there's an election coming up
she could win how could that happen
right now Tucker we are 12 days away
from the city's election and as you know
we've been pushing hard to ensure that
she does not have a path forward but
it's amazing amazing in a city like
Chicago that we have so many individuals
who are hiding behind white guilt and
privilege as an excuse to stick with the
failed mayor rather than hold her
accountable for what she's done and what
she continues to do to this beautiful
city they're willing to stick by here
just to Sage their personal guilt of
privilege or whatever they wokeness
whatever they want to call it and many
of us continue to fight back I know you
had Dr Wilson on your show as well who's
standing up to against her we have to
fight back for this city because we
can't allow what's happening here to
become the Mainstay for every
neighborhood and for every iconic part
of Chicago which is overrun by the
homeless overrun by gangs overrun by
criminality and what should be a
welcoming City to all the good
law-abiding people who want to make this
home
boy that is about the most incisive
description of modern politics I've
heard in a long time Alderman Raymond
Lopez of the city of Chicago thank you
thank you Tucker subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight